lots of jurisdictions can see the
benefit of bitcoin all the holders are
political constituency i guess we're
going to get close to the point where
we're going to flip 50 of the electorate
right there's going to be a bitcoiner in
congress there already are there's going
to be bitcoins in the senate they
already are and eventually a bitcoiner
will be president bitcoin's the greatest
brand in the history of the world first
ch first observation it's the greatest
brand in the history of the world what's
brand value brand value is monetary
premium
right the monetary premium of bitcoin is
1.2 trillion dollars right now name
another brand that's worth 1.2 trillion
dollars right so it's the greatest brand
in the world it's the greatest monetary
asset in the world i mean i'm not
counting the dollar because the dollar
is a inflationary asset it's not an
investment if you pick an asset that you
could reasonably expect to protect you
against inflation
bitcoin becomes the most popular one
other you know other than just like
random real estate right just owning
land i guess land was maybe the most
popular one and bitcoin is is that uh
digital property
so
how do i buy all these other things in
africa or asia or anywhere
right it's a very egalitarian asset and
that makes it politically
uh advantageous right i mean
how is it not what politician would say
i don't want you to own your own house
and i don't want you to have economic
freedom right
right i mean so i think that the left
and the right can both agree on that
it's pretty clear it's high velocity
money
the higher velocity than anything but
it's high velocity asset it's a bank in
cyberspace but it's a franchise bank so
anybody in on earth in any jurisdiction
can create their own franchise of the
bank and
what that means right packs full or you
know fill in the blank every crypto
exchange in every country on earth when
they're selling you bitcoin or
exchanging bitcoin they're in essence
creating
you know
uh a franchise bank of bitcoin where
they're marketing it so so bitcoin is
spreading
through
two
incredibly powerful franchises
the bitcoin exchangers who are the
bitcoin banks if you will and it's open
and permissionless right so there's no
you don't have to get a license from the
fdic to have a bank in egypt that deals
in bitcoin
uh and then it's spreading through the
bitcoin miners they're the security
providers so the security the network
operators and the and the bankers
are spreading like wildfire everywhere
and who's an example or well square cash
app right i mean that's an example of a
bitcoin bank paypal is a bitcoin bank
coinbase is a bitcoin bank finance is a
bitcoin bank right
and uh and when you look at marathon and
riot and all these bitcoin miners
they're the other side of the network so
i think that it's inevitable
that more and more politicians uh begin
to support the network
not everyone will but
but um you know the game theory of it is
such that
the more hostile one regime is the more
lucrative it is for another regime right
it was a benefit to the united states
when china banned the bitcoin right
cracking down on bitcoin mining was a
gift handed to the west and i've you
know i've said it before i think it's
worth a trillion dollars
right and uh you can see it in the hash
rate statistics
um i but at some point
it's so
bitcoin mining is the most lucrative use
of energy in the world
oh that's hands down in the world right
very provable and very verifiable in the
and it's it's the best use of
intermittent energy and the best use of
sustainable energy
and so
when you look at it that way you know
you're thinking well
shouldn't we expect an avalanche more of
political support
and the answer is yes and and why is it
why is it um
stable it's stable because the bitcoin
miner is gonna and the bitcoin holders
are going to go wherever the politicians
support them and they're going to bring
their capital and they're going to pay
taxes
large sums of taxes so
the right way to think about bitcoin is
bitcoin's creating an opportunity
it's an opportunity for your family to
save money for a hundred years it's an
opportunity to fix your company
microstrategy stock is
you know hitting 800 right it's it's an
opportunity for your shareholders it's
an opportunity for your taxpayers it's
an opportunity for your constituents
it's it's an opportunity in the media
business right i mean
nobody wants to talk about anything but
bitcoin
everyone's talking about bitcoin it's an
opportunity for twitter it's an
opportunity for every mobile app it's an
excellent political strategy it's an
excellent marketing strategy it's an
excellent shareholder relations strategy
it's an excellent business strategy